happy Valentine's Day let's talk about
making babies shall we figures about
time then science fun science fun
science is a science of fun yeah so
personally I find reproduction to be one
of the most irresistible topics to learn
about in science I think this is for a
couple of reasons one because I'm a
human and humans like to reproduce we're
pretty good at it too but also because
so much of reproduction it's just so
incredibly weird it's a variation of mad
and wonderful and disgusting methods
that organisms on this planet used to
reproduce is so vast but every single
different possible type of reproduction
that exists on this planet fits into
just two different groups asexual
reproduction and sexual reproduction
asexual reproduction is the method
whereby the offspring is an exact
genetic copy of its parent a clone
basically and this can happen in a
number of different ways as fission
where the original organism grows and
splits itself into two separate
organisms this is what bacteria used to
reproduce there's budding where a large
organism creates a little bud on its
surface with the correct genetic
material in it that then breaks off and
grows on its own it's how yeast
reproduces and then there's also
vegetative reproduction where you take a
cutting from a plant plant that cutting
in the ground and let it grow into its
own organism sexual reproduction on the
other hand the one that you're probably
more familiar with is where two cells
from two separate organisms a male cell
and a female cell combine and grow to
form an offspring that has a mix of
genetic material from both of its
parents man sex oh yeah for most people
though the interesting bit doesn't seem
to be the cells and their genetic code
but it's the method by which these two
cells are allowed to meet each other in
humans just as it is in many other
animals a male makes a bunch of male
cells inserts them into the female using
the pair's sexual organs a single male
cell fertilizes a single female cell and
a baby grows inside the female until
it's ready to pop out however in no way
is this the normal method that nature
uses when it comes to sexual
reproduction it's just the one that we
are most familiar with
for obvious reasons take the ciothes for
example in this case the female inserts
her eggs into the male and then the male
fertilizes them and incubates them and
eventually gives birth to them all by
himself and then there's the mountain
slug which there aren't any males or
females just Tamara Deitz which means
that every
you'll has both male and female sexual
organs in this instance two slugs hang
off a tree branch together by a string
of their own slime release their sexual
organs from behind their heads and then
fertilize each other for about an hour
or so before biting each other's sexual
organs off and actually even though some
plants reproduce asexually some of them
reproduce sexually as well in fact the
flower is actually a plant's sexual
organ with both the male and the female
parts inside of it but the variation
doesn't stop there because there are
actually some animals that have decided
to start reproducing asexually as well
like there are certain types of shark
and lizard that have just given up on
men entirely and just have babies anyway
and yes those babies are exact genetic
clones of their mothers it actually
raises quite an interesting question
which is that if there are animals in
the world that can reproduce asexually
why do men exist why are you required
and with that why the sexual
reproduction exists what what is the
point of it unfortunately the answer is
relatively simple when it's this sexual
reproduction allows for more variation
it means lots of different organisms
with lots of different traits which in
turn means a higher chance of survival
imagine for example that all of a sudden
the whole world just got really really
cold if you're an organism created by
asexual reproduction and you couldn't
handle the new weather you would die and
not only that but every single other
individual in your entire species would
also die however if you're a species
produced by sexual reproduction although
some of you will probably die others may
have nice thick skin or big furry coats
or they might be smart enough to make a
fire they have these extra traits that
allow them to adapt the environment
around them and continue to survive and
that I think is why we are so wired to
be so fascinated by reproduction to
think that it's so important to think
that it's something taboo something
that's awkward to talk about something
that we've created whole ceremony
surrounding because it is the thing that
has allowed us to evolve and exist in
the first place to survive nature just
prefers sex and frankly so do I should I
have done the wink I can always cut it
out you've just had the almost
imponderable joy of watching Charlie is
so cool like which makes you like cool
I made the room pink Jonah yeah
video-making